>> Bob: YOU KEEP SHOOTING WHEN
YOU HAVE THE HOT HAND LIKE THEY.
>> Bob: CASEY HAD A GREAT WEEK
IN PRACTICE.
I WOULD SAY LONGER THAN THAT,
ENERGY LINE FOR THE FLAMES.
HOPING TOO
REMEMBER.
>> Steve: BLOCKER SAVED SA*EUFR
MADE BY DA
>> Bob: DO YOU WANT PLAY TH GETH
NIGHT.
FOUR.
HE GOT HIS FIRST HIS STICK IN TE
AT THE LAST SECOND IT CAME OFF
ZUCKER
MARKSTROM ABLE TO GET OUT RIGHT
>> Steve: GUENTZEL, IN FRONT FO.
ZUCKER DID THAT BUT RIGHT IN THE
MID OF THE FLAMEO MIKE MATH STO.
POPO MOVEMENT.
>> Steve: 20-PLUS MINUTES.ALGAR.
>> Steve: CLOGGING UP THE
BOARDS, KEEPING IT IN MONAHAN. N
MARKSTROM WHO STOPPED ALL 1
CAN GET A SHOT OFF.
BACK THROUGH, FRIEDMAN THE
11:43 TO GO IN THE SECOND.
ONE EVEN, VERY QUICKLY. MAN IS
WILD GAME IN FLORIDA.
LOUGH ANGLE.
TOUGH TO BEAT A GOAL FRIDAY
OFF ICE, GAUDREAU.
WANTS THE BREAK WALL. UP.
NOT IN THE 90 DEETs.
>> Steve
SHOT AS HE'S MOVING BACKWARDS BY
THE GLOVE AND THEIRCLE, SHOOTS,K
AT THE BE.
PETTERSSON AROUND FOR GUENTZEL.
TWO-ON-ONE, GUDBRANSON.
LITTLE PIECE OF T IN.
FIRES, HE SCORES, DUVET
SHOT.
IT APPEARED HE WOULD SHOOT FAR
SIDE.
LOOK AT HIM TURN THE WRIST OVER.
AND HE